hello
congratulations how are you i am doing
very very well and it's largely because
of you guys right now
that's sweet wow
jasmine i'll start with you here you get
one speech in the movie that is above
and beyond one of my favorite parts of
it so i'm curious if you could tell me
what is it like delivering a monologue
like that where you are poking fun at
this franchise and horror in general but
you know having it come across in a
loving way and not it being dismissive
because that's a quality of the phone
that meant a lot to me oh thank you for
sharing that with me
it was exciting and terrifying there's
this feeling of i don't want to let
anyone down i know that i'm representing
an entire community in this monologue
and that these words are true and that
people do feel this way about this film
and other films and and i have so much
love for
for that community of people who are so
passionate i'm i'm a nerd for broadway
like i feel like i could apply the same
thing as you might feel about horror
films to to broadway and musicals and
like i just had to approach it as if i
was talking about
the revival of company or something you
know what i mean because i identify
gutturally also i would like all
attention to be pointed at how many
times she had to do that monologue and
how every single time it was done with
the same amount of energy and
like enthusiasm you know why because i
got to look in these beautiful eyes like
it was the whole cast was just sitting
there fully present with giving me the
energy you want to talk about broadway
people who were basically doing a play
while we were just sitting and wow she's
really acting
it was anyway
it was an honor and it means a lot to me
that you
but it resonated with you and that you
felt that's right i felt good about it
very very much so i felt like you were
talking to me and for a movie to be able
to achieve that is is really something
special it's funny we were talking right
to you actually they said
that's really funny i mean there's
there's a lot of very precise details
you know so i wouldn't be surprised
mason did you have
to do i guess any like backstory work
with matt and tyler in terms of why chad
grew up to be so different from randy
whereas mindy his twin sister has so
many of his qualities i think mindy
takes up so much space in the randy uh
atmosphere of the family that he would
have no choice but to try and break away
at least in some emotional way he's also
very invested in his girlfriend and like
his social life not that randy wasn't
very social but i think we in a
different way i think it speaks for
himself when i think chad found uh more
sanctity in
finding more um
mainstream ways of
like playing sports and uh apparently i
love their little things about chad that
if you watch the movie you find out he's
really
a dork like
i won't spoil anything
that kind of played into it
yeah right because i'm a big dork
yes he is but i mean that in the best
way mason is just so
present in scenes and so funny and has a
mind that i've never seen before and i
mean that as a compliment like would
just say the funniest impress i've ever
heard to the point that sometimes we
would break character
because he's so funny
so with that in mind i know you guys are
working with a top-notch script here but
what is something that you both brought
to your characters that's purely your
own whether it's i don't know like a
line of dialogue a quality you wanted to
add a piece of wardrobe you name it um i
can say right now and i cannot say what
the line was jasmine had the most
brilliant
improv line i don't know what you're
talking about i'll tell you in a moment
but she had the most brilliant line that
was so
funny everyone on set behind the camera
at any point started laughing to the
point where i i doubt they could even
use the ticket i don't know it's not in
the movie oh
oh then why can't you say it if it's not
in the foe
hilarious
and yeah hence why i can say with
confidence that jasmine is actually the
greatest improviser ever okay on her
feet actually we're gonna have to circle
back i need to know what that is i will
i will eventually once everyone's seen
the movie y'all shoot us a tweet and
truly let you know fair enough i also
would spoil if i shared so
yeah we'll just have to leave it at that
keep it to yourself ourselves
pokemon thing was that pokemon
improvised and then
i can't oh no no no that was that was
scripture oh i love that too that was
scripted anyway anyway
all right mason so i believe this is
your first horror movie so
what is it about you know what it takes
to make a bloody slasher movie that felt
super different or surprised you
compared to the other genres that you've
worked in how
i'd say like
funny idiot because it is funny to work
with people so closely both behind the
scenes
and just on set doing certain horrific
scenes with people and you've you know
ate lunch with these people and then
they're
acting their asses off being horrified
or exhausted and then it's like cut and
you're like so anyway
but
um to work on a horror film in general
probably is only emblematic of
or you know a small microcosm of what it
is to work in on something like scream
that is such a story
and long-standing franchise iconic in
which that was
incredibly um
exciting as well as scary but
the actual act of doing it very funny
very fun very exciting
um
yeah a treasure a treat
a treasure treat and delight delighted
me i like all those descriptors kind of
the opposite question for you jasmine
these aren't the same sub genre of
horror but was there anything that you
picked up while working on sound of
violence or yellow jackets that you
found coming in handy when you hit the
screen set yeah you know you're going to
be dirty it's going to get dirty and
that's just got to be okay that's right
that's what it's funny because both you
and jack have done projects where you
were just just hovered and blind and
dirt and it's not like you can go hey
guys now that we wrapped i'm going to go
grab drinks yeah you really can't do
that you're going to go to the shop or
you could but you're going to get some
looks that's right so you just get used
to just being a little certain sticky
little stinky it's a little stinky okay
that's not necessarily well that's
because i was using a natural deodorant
and it wasn't doing the job
i've found a better brand it works
anyway
if you had to give someone else some
advice for jumping into their first
horror movie and being in that kind of
situation in order to power through it
what would it be don't get the cheap
natural deodorant you gotta spring for
the like 15 dollar one you are speaking
to a
true experience it is a matter of like
make sure you're ready to be exhausted
it's embarrassing i was going in a
different way but yeah you don't want to
stink but there's a really good
endorsement opportunity here
you can endorse me
yeah yeah yeah foreign that leaves it
open now all the owner and companies
know this aluminum free
good for the good for the body smells
nice last 12 hours i'm available yeah
there it is
all right we got we got a lot of
important information out there and
somehow i managed to steer clear of
spoilers without you know stressing
myself out or making my head explode but
oh my god you guys did it thank you so
much for honoring the franchise that
means so much to me congratulations
thank you so much have a good day
you